all right Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania it's out maybe you've seen it
maybe you haven't but this is a spoiler
Talk video I'm going to talk about
spoilers so that's a spoiler warning for
you if you haven't seen the movie you
might not want to watch this or you
haven't seen the movie you don't care
too but you want to hear about spoilers
which I see that happening more and more
in the comment section hey to you
welcome as well also as this is a
spoiler Talk video I'm not going to talk
about everything in the movie just some
points that I wanted to make some points
that have to do with how I see the movie
some problems I had with the movie that
were too spoiler-ish for the
spoiler-free review not gonna be a
play-by-play as much as we might want to
hear me be like oh yeah and Bill Murray
talks with Michelle Pfeiffer and I guess
they had a relationship in the quantum
realm it's one scene it doesn't matter
so we move on point is
point is my dogs bark hey pups stop
point is the funny thing about the
conversation about this movie it's
generally been the same positive review
negative review I'll say the same thing
Jonathan Majors very shagadelic baby
yeah the rest of the movie having said
that I do have some thoughts how that
hits whether or not that means positive
or negative depends on the individual
it's kind of a funny thing to me so new
to spoiler talk do we want to do the you
want to do the Sour Patch Kid thing you
know first I'm sour then I'm sweet what
do you want first the good news or the
bad
I guess I'll do the good first that
would be Kang I just love Jonathan
majors in the movie as Kang I thought he
was a great villain charismatic scary at
times so in this movie I was surprised
we actually get the Kang back story or
at least backstory enough to show why
he's the big bad in the quantum realm in
the quantum universe and don't take a
shot every time I say Kang in this video
I don't want you to die Kane crashes in
the quantum realm on his ship Michelle
Pfeiffer and him they'll work to try to
get the ship up and running again she
does the thing the movie does the thing
where she touches the quantum core the
power source and gets all these Visions
because I guess that's how it works I
mean I've seen Smallville do that that
was fine I don't know when
what a 90s plot point but anyhow she
gets Vision she's like oh you're super
bad I'm gonna make your core grow and
you can't get out of here so Kang's just
stuck there and it's kind of cool that
he made his prison his Fortress his
Empire so now that the whole ant fam is
there now King cares Scott Lang floating
around for a few hours or a few years to
us after the second Ant-Man movie and
before end game he was like I don't care
now that they're all here I do care so
now we know what we're up against with
the ant fam is up against in this world
in this Quantum realm Kang is down there
he needs their help to get out and so
now he's it's what I liked about Kang he
comes down has a conversation with them
and he's like you help me or I'm gonna
kill her in front of you and I'm Gonna
Make You relive that [__] over and over
and over again I like me a good villain
with some solid threats more importantly
a good villain with solid threats you
know he will follow through with he's
not messing around also enjoyed the fact
that he seemed magical you know it's
like he had these powers and it seems
like magic but it's all technology is
his Tech is so Advanced it looks like
magic even in an MCU world where you
feel like we've seen it all took me back
to the first Thor movie where you're
like oh they're not magical Gods they're
just really technologically powerful
that's why I like that then the MCU
adopted magic so we've seen a lot of
magic since then it was cool to see Tech
that's so Advanced it feels like magic
we've seen some Advanced Tech in the MCU
but it still felt like Advanced Tech
this was it was something else entirely
for me I enjoyed the fact that it felt
like that also this is a conqueror who
will actually do his own Dirty Work he
does not like he has I mean he has
minions but he doesn't solely rely on
the minions when the [__] was going down
when all the the big battle was
happening he goes down there and starts
shooting fist lasers he like Thanos was
there to do it himself I respect a
villain and a conqueror who will do that
jumping forward a bit but again like I
said this isn't a play-by-play but this
movie came dangerously close to making a
call making a leap that I felt was
impossible for the MCU and that's if
Kang actually killed Scott Lang I know
you don't like hearing that I mean I
like Scott we all like Scott he's the
everyday guy who became a superhero who
doesn't like Scott however what I love
more is a good tragedy and a good death
that's really what we want for Our
Heroes that's all any of us could really
hope for actually most of us are going
to die in our own [__] and piss in our
bed it's gonna be stupid so in a world
where we accept that all we want for Our
Heroes is them to go out like a badass a
couple of them have gotten that
opportunity but really nonsense so when
Kang was handing Scott's [__] ass to
him which they showed one of the
trailers I guess that was weird I
usually have a rule like oh if it's in a
trailer it's free game to show in a
review and I was like not that that's
why did they show that that line that he
has that again is also in the trailer
where he was like I don't have to win we
just both have to lose like Shane these
all bleedings asses beat and I was like
he might actually die he's actually a
pretty thrilling feeling and then it
didn't happen and he beats Kang and well
he gets to go home and I was like
MCU safe Zone every time sorry that
bothers me it would have been so badass
for him to go out protecting his family
that's all the dude wants to do really
there is a compelling family story in
here that's buried under mountains of
CGI [__] that's just there to
shatter and overwhelm your synopsis but
it is there it's just it's it doesn't
hit the point homes that Scott is just
trying to protect his family he's like
Scott's the embodiment of that guy from
the movie The Core
don't you laugh at my guilty pleasures
you stop you know that dude is like
we're trying to save the world that's
impossible I'm just trying to save three
this guy is just there to save his
family you keep it simple like that it's
all in perspective and you will fight
the good fight and you will go out if
you have to go out I always love that
line from that movie and it's funny that
the core hammered that point home better
than Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania I
think it would have been fulfilling if
he had died for his family look I'm a
dark son of a [__] I just like [__]
like that I will say as much as I liked
Kang in this movie when I had time to
really think about it and think about
the makeup of the entire film and what
it's leading to and you know you have
this post-credits scene with multiple
kangs like an auditorium full of kings
and a council full of kangs and when I
think about that I'm like
well I don't care about those kangs I
care about this guy in this movie and I
I left the movie theater and did my
review thinking yeah this is the guy
this is the guy we're going to see again
that's not necessarily guaranteed I
suppose it's a big unknown to even talk
about we don't know exactly where this
is all going to go granted there was a
movie called Kang Dynasty maybe that was
the big Auditorium full of kangs but I'm
kind of afraid that they're gonna do a
thing where it's like oh hey this is the
new Kang in this movie and well I mean
well you got to take him out all right
Kang Dynasty has another Kang in a world
where this is the big Kang is on the big
screen for the first time he's come to
play he's come to make [__] happen I'm
now attached to that Kang and I just I
want the guy in this movie to be the
king we have to deal with or they have
to deal with going forward I don't want
Kang to be like Kenny from South Park
where you just kill him in every new
movie you know this is a new gang but
that's where the other post I mean I
guess I'm talking about both post credit
scenes right now here we are but the
post-credits scene where it's Loki and
Owen Wilson from the Loki series and
there's the scientist who's there oh and
Wilson's like what it made him sound
like some big scary guy he's not scary
what are you talking about I don't even
feel the need to say the word wow so I
proceed assuming that that scientist
Kang is the guy that we just saw it's
just the early years of him which makes
me think are we gonna see the Kang from
this movie in other movies but it's
before the events of quantumania is he
alive after the events of quantumania
did he just get sucked into the quantum
Realms Quantum realm in a world where
the quantum realm to us is smaller than
atoms but they're still drinking water
have Sands have light because apparently
there are photons that they're smaller
than so apparently they have their own
molecular level in their own Quantum
Realm by implication anyway I mean
really you just go on forever with that
you just keep going the point is Kang
has been built up since the Loki series
we finally saw Kang and since this is
the first Kang we saw and in my opinion
he crushed it don't bring in New Kings
it that'll just be like we're meeting
Kang for the first time I'll be met with
that same feeling from Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness where it was
mordo and I was like oh great mordo's
back oh no this is a different mordo
from a different reality not the mordo
from the first Doctor Strange movie that
had all the setup I felt like I had
never met this character before so I
don't do that with Kang but the funny
thing is is when Scott Lang was like I'm
an Avenger he was like
it all gets confusing after I've killed
you that many times are you the one with
the hammer at first I was like [__] does
he kill Thor but it does say I mean he
takes out different realities and
different multiverses so there are
realities and multiverses where the
Avengers have tried to stop this guy and
he has killed them which brings me to my
point friends
might need a little help on this one
don't worry it's a good thing I don't
just do the YouTuber thing and drink to
deal I also drink to celebrate cheers I
always found it so stupid
that Thor and Thor love and thunder I
know I'm bringing up love and thunder
again
another drink for thinking about it but
it always bothered me because I am a
lover of the original Thor movie I love
the first Thor movie I know some out
there might be like he just said what
now opinion is invalid I don't care Thor
learned so many lessons in that first
Thor movie about collateral damage
responsibility there's a coming-of-age
story that in love and thunder it's like
he forgot all of it that's because Thor
love and thunder is actually one of the
variant timelines the Thor and Thor 11
Thunder is not the Thor from the first
Thor movie and Thor from Thor 11 Thunder
is the Thor that Kang has killed not the
Thor from the first Thor movie and the
Avengers it's not actually factual but
you cannot take that away from my head
Cannon it's real to me because I got
this far in this video without even
talking about Modoc
now I'm drinking to forget Modoc was
[__] in this movie is actually the
embodiment you know when I say I start
bitching I bring my old man energy to
the room and start bitching about people
being quippy and characters are quippy
that shouldn't be quippy Modoc is the
embodiment of that because Modoc should
have a Modoc voice maybe I'm just used
to Modoc having a Modoc voice but this
Modoc was just like uh yeah hey Scott
what's up so uh remember me it's like a
Family Guy character or something also
they changed him to be the the guy from
the first Ant-Man movie Yellow Jacket
Darren that's his name but his face was
so [__] which is a bummer because the
rest of the movie
just in terms of landscape looked pretty
good I thought it looked great actually
modoc's head looks like it was in the
wrong aspect ratio he's like hey Scott
what's up it's me it's everyone's
favorite [__] I was like this can't
this can't have been the final product
but I'm in a movie theater it is and
that's a big change they made with Modoc
he wasn't Darren he's he's not they made
him a different character and it felt
wrong again not a Modoc Super Fan but I
can at least recognize and appreciate
when they completely [__] up a character
he felt like the Modoc version of
Deadpool in X-Men Origins Wolverine or
Taskmaster in the Black Widow movie just
these characters are the characters in
name but these moments in the MCU show
me how there has been a decline in the
MCU the mcu's to be the thing where it
was like all right I'm making a real
attempt at bringing the Avengers to the
big screen we're gonna do it the best we
can and I'm comparing MCU villains to
characters from pre MCU like characters
from X-Men Origins Wolverine but there
is definitely an ever-growing sense of
inconsistency in terms of the product
the MCU is churning out to us in the
movies we get yes but also the
inconsistency in the on green Universe
they've gone from dramas that have
comedy with a comedic character to
comedies that might have a dramatic
moment that's compromised by comedy and
everybody
sounds the same everyone's written to
have the same kind of dialogue and
quippy one-liners that cut the tension
all the time there's no distinguishable
difference there's no character that
does that's probably why they don't have
Michael Pena in this movie he used to be
the comedic relief character now it's
like well everyone's comedy relief we
don't need a comedy relief character one
for Michael Pena but also in terms of
the earned journey of the characters you
know an entire Act was dedicated to
showing how one of the great weapon
engineers and minds of our time could
make a new weapon when faced with the
scenario of a life and death two-week
deadline also opportunity and wit and
there we go an entire act dedicated to
him making this new machine that would
basically be the armor of his Redemption
Arc now we have college students that
can make Iron Man Tech and Quantum
devices in their garages it just doesn't
feel special at this point no matter how
big the last Act is no matter how much
[__] you have going on with the big
throwdown at the end you have to care
and Scott Lang almost made me care
but I was rooting for Kang I don't know
what to say I guess he was the character
that was given the most an actor that
did the most alright so Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania have you seen it what
did you think about it I can ask you
that now whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]